just read that up threw you under your
jump up and I can just see your lap and
then I'll
I'm in a lab in the school in Adelaide
in South Australia the reason why it's
so important is the time sitting in the
place that Brady Haran our video
journalist who makes all the videos sat
when he was a pupil so imagine the
little Brady sitting here looking at
that periodic table and thinking wow
chemistry this is the very periodic
table that Brady sat looking at and
they've still got the same periodic
table you can see some of the exciting
elements hassium and so on are missing
but that's the one that made him think
what's the periodic table all about the
thing that really puzzled Brady was that
there were all these elements in fact
most of them in the periodic table that
the teacher never mentioned so what was
it all about
and that's why he wanted the videos so
that eventually he could learn what they
were all about but the thing I want to
do is to meet his chemistry teacher the
person that inspired Brady about
chemistry mr. DeLaughter Denise key but
mr. Denise key does lots of things and
every year he takes a group of students
to a camp outdoor camp teaches them all
sorts of things about the outdoors and
really surprisingly the very week that
we here in Adelaide is the week that
he's in the camp so we've got to go off
to the camp to meet him and I'm really
excited I want to see what was it that
turned Brady on about chemistry
I was going to do medicine yeah and I
chickened out
because I was probably age of 12 and my
father and mother very supportive
parents they allowed me to take school
friends out on camp yeah and by the time
I was 20 then I had to make my choice I
wanted to go to med school but the other
one was a bigger draw card this is it
and I thought well why not combine the
two and I became a science teacher
initially biology then chemistry and
then I went back to uni and did physics
and that's where I ended no it was it
started all in Africa I went to Rhodes
University in South Africa and taught in
Namibia in South Africa itself and then
eventually came out here and that's
where I've been ever since Bradley's
been telling me that you like doing
demonstrations and many teachers now
don't do demonstrations you still do I
do I do and I get into considerable
trouble for it because I like to blow
things up it is my my my big ambition -
every year when the painters comes
through and repaint the splotches in the
labs to put new ones on the ceiling so
yeah I like I like my fireworks and my
sparkies and so do you remember Brady is
a science student I remember his
inquiring mind he was sort of the
fascinated student that his eyes were
there they with you all the time those
buildings there they are toilets there's
a 44-gallon drum underneath and it never
fills up uh-huh you spot him somebody
yeah exactly
okay now have you spotted another we
should because he was grunting they just
now so that means there isn't a lot
about we have a resident family of
koalas in this Creek here in the next
and I generally are here seven of them
okay now I'm looking for two things I'm
looking for koalas but I'm also looking
for some orchids some may be out there
called donkey orchid Martin have a look
at this blue orchid what a stunning
beauty hey you want me give you a hand
okay when this one dies back in three
four weeks that's it and you won't see
it until this time next year so
you actually inspire your students what
do you do that makes them I don't I do
nothing except what's in me already
I am fascinated by science I've got a
passion for for young people and and and
science and all those things that make
life possible and maybe maybe that has
rubbed off or maybe it was in him
already and we just clicked and I think
that's probably the case yesterday